hey apples what's on your mind real
quick ronnie's instagram you know i love
ronnie but it looked like he was worried
about stephanie smoking weed when he's
out of the house he he's sitting there
he's going oh you're drinking vodka
maybe you're smoking weed with him out
no we were doing it together what the
[ __ ] is wrong with this guy he's the
biggest creep dude just just hang up on
him are you smoking weed now once in a
while what about gummies are you into
that at all i'm scared of the edibles
dude try a little one ron dude
could i don't hear anything i don't
think there's a bad connection
all here is static
but uh the guy's a creep dude all he
does is is worry about everybody else
show what they do and he follows and
watches every move everybody makes yeah
did you close on the house ron
why why you lis dude i don't hear that
that's a that's a cool question close on
the house yeah
shut up don't [ __ ] ask me questions
because now i won't answer anything from
him now okay
just hang up the goddamn phone
howard will you ask him
who would you ask did you um
when are you closing on the house
dude hang up on him and i'll talk to you
all you want a minute come on man i'll
answer every question you want man
just hang up on this [ __ ] you know
ronnie went out to vegas because you
know he wants to cram in these last
couple of years and have fun and stuff
and i want him to have fun but
i think he's like trying to cram
everything in since he got to vegas he
no dude we just telling everyone this
morning about how he was out until 4 00
a.m last night the first time the first
time in yeah but i'm just worried about
you two [ __ ] years i've been out are
you gonna pace yourself or are you gonna
go wild out there listen a friend of
mine came in we hung out i haven't seen
him since i left new york and he uh he
came in for something
and uh
we hung out it's uh saturday night just
don't break somebody ought to study
ronnie
and see what it is he's not doing that
allows him to do all these things i
gotta you know what i think it is he
doesn't have a whole lot of thoughts
that
you know that upset him or give him
emotion and i admire ronnie for that
it's like he's like a simple
you know it's like hmm weed good
pity good
[ __ ]
drinking weed
[Laughter]
apple stinks i don't have no stress well
i got i got doors my window should be
i'm sleeping in the freezer and the
sinks are sideways apples
you think you got problems
yeah
[ __ ] you i was worried about you ronnie
don't worry about me i am a fan i care
about you i know you're a good person
even if you're too much on your heel or
the that's your problem why don't you
guys go off the air and talk about this
you